what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are finally here we are finally here at
Secret Wars issue number one the start
of Secret Wars 2015 and I am so excited
here I am so psyched because Marvel has
basically taken the axe to all but like
ten people from the earth-616 universe
everybody else's dish it's insane what
they've done here so if you guys recall
in our last video what we had talked
about was that with the incursion
beginning to happen with the incursion
taking place between the earth-616
universe and the ultimate universe that
if one of the planets wasn't destroyed
if one of the earths wasn't destroyed
that both realities are going to be
destroyed entirely and so in response to
this Nick Fury from the Ultimate
Universe launched an invasion against
the earth-616 universe in order to
annihilate the superheroes and destroy
that earth so that both universes could
continue to exist and so this is where
the story picks up the story basically
picks up here where the in care the
invasion is taking place now in the
midst of this invasion we see a
multitude of heroes it's basically all
hands on deck the guardians of the
galaxy are present the x-men are present
Luke Cage iron fist Danny ran Carol
Danvers spider-man the Fantastic Four
all these different characters have all
popped up from all over the planet earth
to try to stave off this invasion but
what's also taking place here is that
Reed Richards and the Fantastic Four are
trying to organize this multiversal life
raft again this is a life raft it's
basically been designed to house a
certain number of people presumably
around sixty that will allow all these
individuals to survive the collapse of
the multiverse should it take place and
then survive into the next whatever the
next step multiverse happens to be and
so what we find here is that there
eventually comes a point whereby it
seems as though nothing can be done that
too much time has passed it's impossible
to destroy the the earthly ultimate
universe without destroying both earths
in the process simple because of their
proximity and the fact that if the
ultimate universe version of the earth
or if the main earth was destroyed it
would simply just blow up both of them
just due to the fact that the explosion
would be so extreme
and so what happens here is the
Fantastic Four implied Panther
effectively use the the multiversal life
raft to begin reaching out to the
various heroes that they need that will
help them move on into the next
multiverse and so the following heroes
are picked up the following heroes
continue to be part of what we'll see
going into battle world we see Peter
quill joins this team along with the
all-new version all new a female version
of Thor followed by Peter Parker
spider-man Carol Danvers and Cyclops who
has basically readjusted or retaken back
on the Phoenix force and this is it this
is all we get now of course this is in
addition to the Fantastic Four and to
out Black Panther but this is really
always see these are the only characters
these about nine or ten people are the
only ones for the main earth-616
universe that are presumably going to
live on into whatever this new battle
world is going to be and so what happens
here is that while the group is trying
to make their escape trying to simply
survive the collision of both of these
earths that there's all kinds of
electrical storms there's all kinds of
chaos due to the instability of these
realities colliding with one another and
that during this time these section
which basically holds Susan storm Johnny
Storm Ben Grimm and the fantastic four
children is ripped away and so what
happens is Reed Richards tries to launch
this kind of rescue attempt in the sense
that he tells the chala to lower the
shield's now initially to tell it
doesn't want to and the reason being
because if they did it might cause some
kind of an instability within the ship
and it would end up destroying the
multiversal life raft entirely and so
what he says is that he'll be able to
lower it down for five seconds but after
that five seconds is up if the integrity
of the ship goes below 90% then he's
going to have to raise the shield
regardless of what's happened and so
once the shield goes down Reed Richards
tries to reach out to Susan storm and to
grab that section of the ship but right
before he gets there that section of the
ship disintegrates entirely and so
basically Reed Richards is the only
member of the Fantastic Four left
everybody else has been completely
annihilated and so what we find is that
as everything seems to come to an end as
this entire multiverse begins to
collapse and to basically be destroyed
that we
see that this multiversal liferaft seems
to land on what this new battle world is
I guess on the the formation of the
conglomeration of all these different
realities that have been merged on to
what battle world is going to be but
again this is what we get we don't
really know what's going to happen next
the only indication we have is from what
Marvel has told us through various
interviews and so on that Secret Wars
issue number 2 is going to cover all
these different realities but the fact
remains in terms of the earth-616
portion of battle world that is to say
the portion of battle world that's going
to house the characters from that were
previously part of the earth-616
continuity these are the only ones we're
going to see that we're going to see
Reed Richards we're going to see Black
Panther we're going to see Carol Danvers
Cyclops with the Phoenix force Peter
Parker spider-man the only version of
for Peter quill and maybe one or two
other people but that's it this is all
we have left
so keeping with our series of videos on
secret Wars we pick up now with Secret
Wars number two and I won't tell you
guys right now this is a damn good story
the super secret Wars number one
concluded with the end of everything the
end of the Marvel multiverse and the
destruction of presumably a multitude of
characters The Secret Wars number two
picks up with the beginning of battle
world with the beginning of everything
now as we get into this video what I
want to make clear here is that some of
the things that we're gonna see in this
video we're simply just not gonna have
answers to yet we don't know what a lot
of these things will turn into and so
while I'm sure you guys will have a lot
of questions I'll answer them as best I
can but some of them we just don't have
an answer to what I also want to guys to
keep in mind here is that the notion of
alternate realities is no longer part of
the equation that there are no more
there's no more earth-616 there's no
more ultimate universe there's no more
as Marvel Zombies universe none of that
stuff and said there's simply just
battleworld and so over the course of
this video while I referenced things
like earth-616 and while I referenced
things like the ultimate universe that's
simply just to give you guys perspective
that's to help you guys understand these
characters and reference to who they
used to be as opposed to who they are
now so what we do as we start this
series is we pick up with some young man
who has successfully lifted the hammer
of Thor which is basically our
introduction to the Thor core
as is explained to us by Odin Thor who
appears to be basically the leader of
the Thor core the Thor core is
essentially the police force of
battleworld and they carry out the will
of the god of battle world or of this
reality who's actually revealed to us to
be Doctor Doom and what we also do is we
join Odin Thor as he takes this newest
recruit of the Thor Corps on a tour of
battle world what were given is this
sort of origins story where prior to the
existence of battle world there was
nothing and then everything came into
existence presumably at the hands of
Doctor Doom
what's this basically telling us here is
that the four core are pretty much
unaware of anything having ever existed
before the end of the Marvel multiverse
and the establishment of battle world
now again we don't know this for a fact
this just appears to be the case more so
than that we don't know if anybody else
on battle world believes this at this
moment is simply just given to us this
seems to be the perspective of the four
core but what we do is we find that in
the key note of you topless we actually
move away from the Thor core here and we
find that we pick up with the Captain
Britain core and the Captain Britain
core under this under the kingdom of you
topless appear to have several
scientists that have uncovered some kind
of a vessel and this vessel appears to
be the raft that was used by Reed
Richards and the various heroes from
earth-616
to escape the collapse of that universe
the destruction of everything and
survive into the I guess the the
creation of battle world and this a new
reality now from here we rejoined I
guess Odin Thor we pick up with his
character and this recruit as they
arrive at bar-sinister which is the
kingdom of mr. sinister and again as
they basically exist to carry out the
law of doom this is what they're doing
what we're told is that sinister has
been ordered in the I guess order to the
presence to appear before Doctor Doom
himself and again this really seems to
give us some very I guess a large amount
of insight into the world that dr. doom
plays as the god of battle world in the
sense that it seems as though Doctor
Doom is really believed to be this kind
of God because what happens here
this sinister makes no attempt to refuse
the order to appear before doom and the
earth-616 continuity sinister was a
character who really didn't know didn't
take orders from anybody he will just
kind of did his own thing but in this
circumstance when he's ordered to appear
before
cardoon while he is very cavalier about
it while he has a lot of attitude about
it he still does it and so the second
thing that we learned here is that it
appears that models basically chosen
some of the most prominent villains from
the earth-616 continuity to be the
leaders of is to be the leader of these
are different these different kingdoms
within battleworld of course mr.
sinister being one of the more prominent
members of our 6-1-6 is the leader of
bar sinister itself and so again what we
find is that we basically pick up with
the arrival of the four core and what's
referred to as doom stat which is the
home of Doctor Doom and it appears as
though this place is guarded by some
form of Galactus now this is a little
bit different from the Galactus that
we're used to in the sense that this
version of Galactus is on fire he has a
fiery head and so on and so forth but
again this simply just appears to be
some version of the Galactus character
and at some point along the line we may
get a little more information about this
but what we end up doing here is once we
join doom inside I guess join another
Thor core and sinister inside of doom
stat Doctor Strange is revealed to us to
be the sheriff of battleworld who
basically upholds the laws of doom
across all of the kingdoms there for any
reason a dispute arises between the
rulers of these various kingdoms the
dispute itself is settled within the
house of Doom in order to basically
maintain peace and to keep Kingdom from
waging war against each other and
evolving about a world into a state of
chaos what we're told is that sinister
apparently has allied himself with
Hyperion the ruler of the kingdom of the
the squadron supreme and that the
intention of them seems to be to
overthrow Jamie Braddock who is a leader
of you topless now as a result Jamie
Braddock is basically requested a
hearing in front of Doctor Doom to
settle this to settle this matter to
settle this dispute but the problem is
that while sinister basically lies to
maintain his innocence he's eventually
found guilty by dr. strange and so as a
result sinister basically chooses to
challenge Brian Braddock the brother of
Jamie Braddock to a battle to the death
now while we're told that sinister has
the right to earn his innocence by
battling someone to the death were not
told why he's able to challenge Brian
Braddock instead of the person who's
accusing him Jamie Braddock but I'd go
as far as to say here that
most likely because sinister is a
representation of his own territory or
possibly because he's the one being
challenged he has the right to challenge
anybody from the kingdom that's
challenging him and so in this instance
he chose a child challenge Brian
Braddock but again I don't really have
any confirmation for this I have no real
basis for this it's just kind of a
theory on my part because I want to make
this make sense in my own mind but
regardless the result is that during the
fight sinister appears to be victorious
but before he's able to deal the deal
the killing blow he's basically stopped
my dr. doom and the reason for this is I
guess his doom explains because dooms
basically uncovered some knowledge which
indicates that there are individuals who
have been plotting against his position
and that these individuals may exist
inside the kingdom of you topless
and so while Jimmy Braddock claims a
lack of knowledge well he says he
doesn't really know anything about this
what doom says is that if Jimmy Braddock
is the ruler of you topless then as a
king of that area he should know
everything that's going on within his
kingdom and that failure to achieve this
failure to do so means that he's
basically not fit to be the king and so
the result is that doom have to be hesse
of Susan storm has Jamie Braddock taken
away Brian Braddock elevated to the
position of the king of Utah Palace and
sinister sentenced to a series of lashes
now what I want to do here is I'm going
to take a break from this entire segment
for a second and I want to talk about
Susan storm and the reason why is
because as we know if Secret Wars number
one it appear that all of the members of
the Fantastic Four with the exception of
Reed Richards had been killed when the
universe collapsed when their lifeboat
had basically kind of broken away and so
on but it appears that dr. doom has
saved them and so while we don't really
know where Ben Grimm or where Johnny
Storm is what we do know is that
Franklin Richards valaria Richards and
Susan storm are alive now we don't know
if some of the other individuals that
we've seen for example mr. sinister or
some of those other characters were
saved by dr. doom we simply just know
that they're here but regardless what we
do here is we pick up with the Thor core
as they prepare to deliver Jimmy
Braddock to his faint after having after
Jimmy Braddock was basically sentenced
by Doctor Doom and what happens is the
group arrives at the shield wall which
appears to be a giant wall stretching
the entire length of battle world which
very seems very similar to the Great
Wall of China here
but what happens is Jimmy Braddock being
sentenced is basically thrown over the
wall and so what we learn is that on the
other side of this wall which is
designed to isolate or to protect all
the kingdoms of battle world there
consists three groups the first group
are the zombies from the Marvel Zombie
universe the second group is the
annihilation wave and Annihilus himself
and the third group is appears to be
just a vast number of robots now what
Odin basically tells his recruit here is
that it appears as though somewhere
along the line that when this wall was
built that various people had been
placed there to defend it and they've
been defending it for years and that
people had died so again it seems as
though if doom really did create battle
world if he really did create this
reality then perhaps he planted the
thoughts in the minds of Aalesund
happened so they've been here for as
long as they can remember though or that
for some reason this is really just kind
of a temporal thing again this is really
kind of confusing here and we don't
really have an answer to this question
although I'm sure that as time
progresses we'll understand why it is
that Odin Thor believes that he's been
here for years when in fact this isn't
the case and the reason why this is not
the case is because what happens is we
jump back to the scientist from the
Kingdom of Utah police who are
investigating this raft that appeared to
belong to the survivors of earth-616 but
what's revealed to us is that the Thor
Corps or at least a small contingent of
the Thor Corps had been assigned here to
basically bring it into this excavation
to take all the items that have been
uncovered by the scientists and to take
them back to to castle doom but when
does up happening is one of the
scientists basically opens this raft
opens the ship and when it does it's
revealed to us this is not the ship that
belongs to earth-616 instead it's the
ship that belonged to the ultimate
universe to the ultimate universe Reed
Richards Thanos and the Cabal and so
what happens is thousand the Cabal come
out and immediately incapacitate this
small contingent of the four core we
didn't see the Thanos is basically
confused about where he's at he has
understand where this world is how this
world got there or how they even got
there and so what happens if Thanos
basically questions the scientists and
the scientist says that while this place
is referred to under a multitude of
different names depending on who it is
that you're talking to it's a highborn
as referred to as as one name if it is a
common person there
to it as battleworld what this basically
means here is that either a very long
amount of time is passed between the
collapse of the universe and the birth
of this new universe which would explain
why Odin says or why Odin Thor says that
they've been protecting it for years or
it could simply just be that almost no
time has passed this reality came into
existence and then now Thanos and these
individuals are coming out of the raft
again this is a little confusing here
but again as we continue with the secret
war story this will all be made to make
sense I have no doubt about that so as
we get into Secret Wars number three
keep in mind that we're going to be
running over these as the release to us
and so we may find that there are
relatively large gaps between each
telling of this story but what we're
gonna find in this portion of the story
is we're going to receive a large bit of
information regarding the origin of
battleworld
having said that in secret Wars number
two if you recall we were given this
sort of tour of battle world and that we
learned that the Thor Corps is composed
of alternate versions of Thor and
individuals from alternate realities
that were deemed worthy of wielding
Thor's hammer and that the Thor Corps
itself basically functions as the police
force of this new battle world now what
we also learned was that Doctor Doom had
apparently constructed battleworld
although we weren't really told how this
was done but due to the vast power that
he seems to possess Doom operates as the
ruler of battle world as a God with
Doctor Strange
I guess acting as the sheriff and
second-in-command to Doctor Doom what we
also learned was that under Doom are a
series of barons with each ruling their
own section of battle world under their
own authority although there is some
measure of what they can and can't do
now at the end of the last story if you
recall we discovered that the life raft
used by the Ultimate Universe to escape
the collapse of their of the multiverse
was discovered and accidentally opened
resulting in Thanos Maximus the mad
neighbor the Submariner and the rest of
the Cabal basically escaping and getting
out into battle world proper now from
here we jump to Doctor Strange as he
investigates the wrath if Thanos and the
Cabal emerged from when after speaking
with several members of the Thor Corps
Doctor Strange tells them to basically
search out and defy
of all but to bring them back alive what
we also find is that dr. strange
realizes that not everyone who was on
board the raft left with a nose
revealing that Miles Morales had
actually stowed away and didn't seem to
be detected by the Cabal themselves in
addition to this as miles begins to
explain how it was he came to be on the
raft dr. strange actually stops him once
he realizes that Miles Morales remembers
everything before and during the
collapse of the multiverse now from here
we transition to dr. strange the newest
Thor recruit in Miles Morales inside of
what's referred to as the Hidden Isle of
agamotto which is to say dr. Strange's
own territory that's hidden away from
the eyes of everybody else presumably
with the exception of dr. doom what
we're told here is that dr. strange was
actually able to preserve elements of
the main Marvel Universe version of the
planet Earth within his own sanctum
sanctorum but that he's also in
possession of the raft that was used by
the heroes of the main Marvel Universe
to escape the collapse of the multiverse
and after Thor is able to actually open
the raft at the request of Doctor
Strange the group is initially greeted
by Peter Parker Carol Danvers Jane
Foster Thor and star-lord
now the initial response by both Doctor
Strange and the remnants of the
earth-616 superheroes is one of
skepticism in that they don't know if
they can trust the others or not but
when the group is actually joined by
Scott Summers as the Phoenix Black
Panther and Reed Richards Doctor Strange
becomes convinced that these are indeed
his friends and so what we do is we get
this sort of explanation from Doctor
Strange with regards to how it was
that battleworld came into existence
what Doctor Strange tells them is that
they've all been in stasis inside this
raft for about eight years or so and
that when the multiverse collapsed doom
began reaching out to what was left of
the multiverse and began rounding up
various pieces of those earths to form
battleworld now keep in mind as Doctor
Strange is giving this explanation he's
not actually referring to Doctor Doom
he's simply referring to this being as
God now in addition to this no one on
battleworld with the exception of a
handful of people have any idea of what
their past universe was like or that it
even existed is for
they're concerned they basically just
came into existence with battleworld and
the reason why they believe this is
because quite literally dr. doom had
modified their memories now when Reed
Richards asked the question who this God
is this is when Doctor Strange reveals
that is Victor Von Doom that dr. doom
had effectively saved all of their lives
now from here we switch back to the
Cabal as they continue to figure out
this new world and as the as the group
basically kind of sits around and they
kind of eat and they debate and so on
the consensus among those talking is
that they should not have killed all the
versions of Thor and instead they should
have basically questioned those members
of the Thor core who are present but the
result is that Thanos responds by simply
saying they will have all the answers
they seek that they seek shortly and
when the questions asked how it is at
Thanos knows this panel simply says that
that he's looking up and so what this
basically tells us is that the Thor core
as it was assigned by Doctor Strange to
track down the Cabal has successfully
done so and it seems as though the four
core is basically descending on Thanos
and his cabal and this is where the
story ends were kind of left to find out
what happens next
in issue number four and so what I want
to do here is cover the fourth part of
Marvel's Secret Wars but because we've
already done a video on why Secret Wars
was launched in the first place and
because of the fact that we don't yet
know what the fallout of the inclusion
of this comic is going to be what we're
going to do here is we're just going to
basically cover the story and as the
events unfold in future publications
we'll tie those in to give a more
well-rounded understanding of what else
going on here
in secret Wars number three we had
discussed that following the collapse of
the multiverse ultimate universe Reed
Richards
Thanos Namor the Submariner and the rest
of the cabal from the mainstream Marvel
Universe had escaped the collapse using
a raft from the ultimate universe itself
in addition to this in Peter Parker
Captain Marvel Black Panther Thor Jane
Foster
star-lord Scott Summers as a Phoenix
force and Reed Richards had all survived
the collapse in a second draft from the
mainstream Marvel Universe and while
eight years had passed on the outside
only a few hours had passed inside the
RAF's
and so when Thanos his group emerged and
after being met with the arrival of a
contingent of the Thor core operating as
a police of battle world Thanos and the
Cabal killed all of them and then left
the area now where Secret Wars number
three had ended on the arrival of the
remaining Thor core after tracking down
fan o's and his group following their
massacre the secret voice number four
picks up with Doctor Strange providing a
narrative relating to the formation of
this new world
what Doctor Strange tells us is that
following the multiversal collapse Doom
Doctor Strange and the molecule man Owen
Reese had killed the beyonders the
orchestrators of the great multiversal
collapse and taking their power doom
reshaped reality and for embattled world
of the process by taking what was left
of alternate universes and placing them
in a singular location although we're
not told exactly how it was he was able
to accomplish all of this while Doctor
Strange serves doom as his
second-in-command his stance on the
function of battle world seems to be a
disappointment and that his view of the
world being a place of constant struggle
and strife is a far cry from what it
should have actually been now while the
group debates the decision of Doctor
Strange in turning away from omnipotence
and allowing doom to take the mantle
instead the hammer of one of the four
core recruits lights up indicating a
request for aid from those battling
Thanos at this point the story
transitions to one of the Thor core
members speaking directly with Doom and
forming him that the battle with Thanos
goes poorly
and while the group may be successful it
would cost the lives of many of the Thor
Court members in order to defeat Thanos
himself in addition to this when valaria
Richards is asked by doom to use her
vast intelligence to analyze a situation
Valerius states that the result of this
battle is impossible to determine the
power wielded by Thanos from the
mainstream Marvel Universe Dwarfs any of
his alternate reality counterparts that
currently exist on battleworld
while doom states as such a conflict is
below his concern the Susan storm tells
him that the power demonstrated by these
individuals goes beyond everyone present
on battle world save doom himself and
maybe dr. strange while doom debates
whether to act or not he witnesses the
arrival of Doctor Strange on the
battlefield alongside the heroes from
the mainstream Marvel Universe and Miles
Morales from the Ultimate Universe
however with the arrival of Doctor
Strange and his forces also comes the
arrival of Reed Richards from the
mainstream Marvel Universe and after
stating that he has spent years
searching every corner of battle world
for him doom states that he's finally
managed to find him and taking this time
to act
doom appears on the battlefield
confronting all forces involved while he
explains to read that his new power
makes him a virtual God if Thanos
responds by simply stating that there
exists a difference between playing God
and truly being a God in addition to
this Scott Summers attached Doctor Doom
is stating that Doom is like every man
playing with a power that he doesn't
understand with a planet being composed
of a multitude of realities each one
home to its own occupants Doom is forced
himself into the role of a leader with
no true understanding of what it means
to lead and that while Scott Summers is
able to hold his own against doom for a
time
doom is able to overpower Scott Summers
and in the process seizes him by the
neck and breaks it killing him in the
process during the entire conflict
between doom and Scott Summers however
Doctor Strange takes the opportunity to
use his power and send the various
heroes and villains away to various
places in battle world although we don't
know how now when asked by doom as to
why he had done this Doctor Strange
simply replies that doom would have
inevitably
held them all due to the fact that they
would never have bent their knees to his
power but furthermore dr. strange
touches on the inherent fear of doom in
that after all the power he's gained and
his stance as a ruler of this new
reality that in the end he still fears
Reed Richards and so in response to what
seems to be the incorrigible nature or
perhaps the insubordinate nature of
Doctor Strange Doctor Doom kills him
entirely so starting off at the funeral
of Doctor Strange there are a few key
things here I would like you to pay
special attention to the first is the
eulogy that's being given the unnamed
man of the Thor Court tells us that in
the beginning there was nothing and that
the great god Doom had created
everything and alongside him stood his
first disciple in the form of Doctor
Strange if you notice there is no
mention of the molecule man the third
man who stood beside doom and strange
and the battle against the beyonders in
order to save the multiverse now this is
something I'd like you to keep in the
back of your head because this will
become particularly important as we
continue with this part of the event the
next thing I'd like you to take notice
of is Franklin Richards when the funeral
proceedings complete Franklin Richards
offers a gift to the statue of dr.
strange in the form of a leaf that he
turns into a wreath now again this is
also important because Jonathan Hickman
is telling us the Franklin Richards
still has the power to work reality
furthermore because Jonathan Hickman
stories all tie into each other with the
events of Franklin Richards making
Galactus is Harold during the Future
Foundation in the mainstream continuity
it's entirely possible the dispersion of
Franklin Richards does possess the same
power now whether this power rivals that
of dr. doom is unknown but what Franklin
tells us is that he plans revenge
against whoever it was that killed dr.
strange indicating that a battle will
take place somewhere along the line
between Franklin Richards and Doctor
Doom now the story begins to transition
away a bit and focus on Valyria Richards
as a daughter of Susan and Reed Valerio
was a character that had a level of
intelligence comparable to both her
father and Doctor Doom as such while she
expresses feelings to doom that her
actions of having previously notified
dr. strange
about the survivors of the ultimate
universe led him down the path that
resulted in his death the show remains
unaware that it was actually do who
killed strange but furthermore in her
mind in the mind of everyone else is
believed that the survivors of the
mainstream in the Ultimate Universe
continuities were actually the ones who
had killed strange and so the question
lingers that if doom himself had arrived
to fight alongside dr. strange how was
it that the survivors got away who all
doomed seems to beat around the bush
here in stating that no one had escaped
the explanation he offers on why they've
not been captured is that in its current
mindset if he were to seek them out he
would immediately destroy them in his
own grief now while this is clearly a
lie Jonathan Hickman leaves this a
little ambiguous as to whether or not
Valyria believes it and so in an effort
to distract her thoughts from DIMMs
involvement or for some reason or
another doom tasked Valyria richards
with tracking down the survivors of the
mainstream and the ultimate universe
continuities now continuing on the
Jonathan Hickman continues this trend of
revealing important aspects of the
events following the collapse of the
multiverse when we learn that the
molecule man Owen Reese is actually
still alive now this is perhaps the most
important aspect of the story because
this gives us some insight into how
battleworld formed how it functioned
prior to the death of Stephen strange
and how his death will change everything
going forward now I'd like you to pay
special attention to the words Hickman
uses here devour hunger and so on
while this could simply mean that Owen
Reese is quite literally hungry for
physical food the running theory among
fans is that molecule man is set to be
the new Galactus again while this is a
theory it seems supported in the
information that follows but what Hitman
does here is seemingly retcon the
creation of everything where previously
was believed that the Enigma known as
the one above all was the driving force
behind everything in existence what
Hickman seems to be telling us here is
that the be honours themselves had
created all things including the
multiverse in addition to this Hickman
revives a bit of consolidation regarding
the events that led up to the
multiversal collapse with the be honours
having looked at their multiverse and
making the decision to basically start
over the molecule man was created and
then split into an infinite number of
versions of himself
which were all placed in every reality
across the infinite expanse of the
multiverse using his ability to control
the molecules of all things
the Beyonder sought to destroy every
version of molecule man simultaneously
which would bring an end to everything
and allow the beyonders to basically
start anew
however learning of their plan doom and
Owen Reese concocted their own plan to
destroy each version of Owen Reese and
were to preserve the multiverse but a
byproduct of this action was that with
each version a molecule man that was
killed in an alternate reality the
mainstream molecule man grew more and
more insane since he was effectively
losing more and more of himself and so
with time running short dooms strange
and Owen Reese abandoned their plan and
instead began collecting molecule men
from the realities that hadn't been
destroyed now during their final battle
with the beyonders the captured versions
of molecule men were dispersed into the
beyonders and detonated like bombs and
so with the beyonders dead but their
powers still present dooms strange and
the last remaining Owen Reese captured
their power seeking to use it in order
to preserve what was left using
fragments of the world that he had
traveled during his time killing the
molecule man doomed peace these
fragments together informed battle world
in addition to this the power of the
beyonders was simply too much for Doom
or dr. strange to control and so using
Owen Reese as a conduit the power of the
beyonders is channeled through the
molecule man and possessed by doom
however what Hickman tells us is that
where dr. doom acted as the power of
battleworld
he was not all-knowing and relied on dr.
strange to operate as an eyes and ears
but because dr. strange is now dead
doom is virtually blind to all things
going on in battle world which has
effectively started a chain reaction
that will eventually lead to its total
destruction now transitioning back to
Valyria Richards we join with the Future
Foundation as a group that was
established in Hickman's run of the
Fantastic Four the Future Foundation
operated as a group of the world's
brightest minds both young and old in
order to solve the world's problems
while the group as it exists now is
composed of a fraction of its original
population under Larry Richards they
establish a couple of important things
for us the first is that everything on
battleworld
is composed of what they refer to as God
particles or the power
do while we know this to be the power of
the beyonders the Future Foundation
doesn't and so they simply state that
everything on battleworld is composed of
this energy now while this might be a
bit of a stretch here I would be willing
to go out on the limb and say that
Hickman is telling us that rather than
doing piecing battleworld together from
what was left of the multiverse instead
all of the realities that exist on
battleworld
were created by doom using the power of
the beyonders but furthermore as it
stated here where dr. Doom's power was
rooted in the beyonders the power
Stephen strange was rooted in magic as a
result when Stephen strange wished the
survivors of the mainstream and Ultimate
Universe continuities away and was
subsequently killed by doom the machines
of the Future Foundation registered two
spikes of energy one by doom and one by
dr. strange using the timeline of
Wendy's energy spike the group seems to
come to the realization that doom killed
strange but his Valerius states all
information gathered on the
investigation will stay with the group
and so as we bring this issue of secret
Wars to a close we find fan OHS facing
the shield which separates the rest of
battle world from the Marvel Zombies and
Ultron indicating that Thanos intends to
use these forces for his own ends
so getting into Secret Wars part six in
truth this comic is actually a little
light on content in comparison to what
we've seen so far where issue number
four saw the death of Steven strange and
the dispersing of the various survivors
from the earth-616 and Ultimate Universe
continuities issue number six continues
the trend of their investigations into
what took place between the collapse of
the multiverse and the formation of
battle world under dr. doom picking up
three weeks after issue number five
which concluded with Thanos standing at
the wall separating battle world from
the Marvel Zombies and Ultron army issue
number six opens up with dr. doom and
Valerio Richards examining the bodies of
Corvus glaive and Proxima midnight
conveniently what Hickman does here is
give us a bit of information regarding
who these two are by way of Black Swan
to provide a little context for the new
people when dr. doom had begun the
process of attending to defeat the
beyonders efforts to destroy the
multiverse
he had amassed an army to help with the
task which were called the black swans
as the sole survivor of the group this
woman took the name Black Swan as a
singular identity and along with a
handful of others survived the collapse
of the multiverse transitioning back to
the story we learned that over the
course of the last three weeks various
territories within battle world have
begun to rise up against doom and while
none of them possess the power to
destroy him outright their efforts have
been driven towards gaining the power
necessary to do so furthermore despite
having been tasked with finding the
surviving superheroes from before the
collapse of the multiverse valaria
Richards have been unable to achieve
this task but as we've discovered an
issue number five she along with several
others have been working against Doctor
Doom to end his rule indicating that
she's most likely lying here this
sentiment is actually compounded on when
the story transitions to the foundation
as a group that appeared during
Hickman's run of the Fantastic Four and
was actually referred to as the future
foundation the purpose of the future
foundation was to bring the world's top
minds together in an effort to develop
various technologies to ensure a
brighter future for the world however
when the collapse of the multiverse
happened the individuals that we see
here were the only members of the
foundation that seemed to have survived
furthermore because valaria has a level
of intelligence on par with both Reed
and doom while she had not figured out
everything that was going on at the very
least she speculated the doom had killed
dr. strange
other than the survivors of our 6-1-6
and the ultimate universe continuities
as a result she and the rest of the
foundation began to focus their efforts
on discovering the source of Doom's
power as well as putting the pieces
together
regarding the battle that took place
resulting in the death of Cyclops as the
Phoenix the vanishing of the survivors
and the death of dr. strange picking up
with both versions of Reed Richards from
the earth-616 continuity in the Ultimate
Universe the conversation between the
two serves to establish the dichotomy of
their outlooks on life and their moral
views for 6-1-6 read the defeat of doom
would likely result in his death which
draws a series of questions regarding
what would happen next however for the
ultimate read the only issue at hand is
the destruction of Jim with everything
else existing as a secondary now this as
a whole isn't wildly important and all
it really does is provide us with their
differing perspectives but also sets up
ultimate read to continue his role as
the villain the maker going into all-new
all-different marvel furthermore the
discussion between the two reveals that
the insurgency within battleworld is not
a disorganized revolt among the various
territories instead someone referred to
as the Prophet is leading these
territories to freedom by helping them
to revolt and then defeating the members
of the Thor Corps when they arrived to
restore order in addition to this we
learned that 6-1-6 read is aware that
his wife Susan his daughter valaria and
his son Franklin serve at the pleasure
of doom and while their memories appear
to have been altered in a manner that
keeps them from recalling their lives
before battle world on a personal level
6-1-6 freed recognizes that unless Doom
is defeated he will effectively have
lost his family transitioning to Castle
doom proper what we find is that Peter
Parker and Miles Morales have been
tasked with locating the source of dooms
power presumably by Reed Richards
however as the to investigate the means
by which doom accesses his power the two
were joined by valerian Richards who
reveals the access point in addition to
this the modification of her memories by
doom are confirmed when Peter recognises
who she is but she does not recognise
him and doesn't know anyone by the name
of Reed Richards and so was the three
begin to talk Valyria admits that she
was willing to help miles and Peter
access the source so long as they answer
the question of who it was that actually
killed dr. strange during the battle
confirming her belief that it was indeed
dr. doom the
he lives up to her end of the bargain
and provides the two with the passage
they seek descending into the white-hot
room the two come face to face with Owen
Reese providing him with a hamburger
that's been in the pocket of Miles
Morales for several weeks
Hickman toys with us a little bit by
hinting at the idea that even if Reese
isn't Galactus per se at the very least
the hunger he suffers from is akin to
Galactus and that he consumed everything
that existed within the white space now
what the contents of this area was is
unknown and hatred never actually tells
us but when Pierre and Miles ask Owen
about the source of Doom's power Reese
responds that he himself serves this
purpose now again this is really Hickman
just leaving things ambiguous and will
most likely be revealed at the end of
the story but for the sake of having a
little fun I would hazard a guess that
when dr. strange Owen Reese and dr. doom
stood against the beyonders at the end
of everything because Reese had the
power to manipulate the molecules of all
things in existence he most likely
defeated the beyonders absorb their
power and now exists as a way for doom
to control that'll world and so picking
up at the Isle of auger motor which
serves as dr. Strange's home the story
begins to get a little more interesting
when we join black panther and name were
the Submariner after entering the to are
met with a magical vision of Doctor
Strange allowing them to continue once
they've proven their identities by
providing a password Doctor Strange goes
on to tell them that if they're seeing
this message is too due to the fact that
he's died as such he left his personal
artifacts to only his most trusted
friends the first object is the siege
courageous unlike the siege perilous
which allows an individual to step
through and have their entire life reset
while being transported to another
location
the siege courageous allows transport in
the same fashion without the loss of
one's memories the second object however
is far more powerful and comes in the
form of the Infinity Gauntlet as he
explains because battleworld as a
singular reality composed of multiple
other realities the Infinity stones were
pulled from these various territories to
form the gauntlet which will work if
it's used now picking up with Susan
storm and Franklin her recollection of
the events during the early days of
battle world come in the form of a
bedtime story but also give us one
interpretation of what has happened
beginning with the formation of the
Fantastic Four the events that took
place leading to the development
of their powers remains the same except
that instead of Reed Richards leaving
the group instead as far as Susan is
concerned it was led by her father
Franklin storm now her recollection of
these events is most likely due to dr.
doom modifying her memories to ensure
that her recollection of Reed does not
interfere with her perspective of the
world as doom had created it but as the
story goes the Fantastic Four existed on
earth and fought villains however when
the multiverse collapsed took place and
battleworld came into existence the
environment was harsh and only the
strongest were able to survive amidst
the chaos during this time Franklin
storm had been killed and during the
pandemonium doom had appeared under the
desire to bring order to the chaos
however before we find out anything else
Susan ends the story and since Franklin
off to bed and so picking up with Thanos
B insurgency within battle world and the
various individuals within continues as
we find him speaking directly with Ben
Grimm during the conversation Grimm
reveals that when battleworld had taken
form an order was restored by doom
because the Marvel Zombies and the
Ultron robots were so dangerous and
would ruin the existence of everything
else doom had requested that Ben Grimm
allow himself to serve as the wall
protecting battle world from each
threats
however Thanos counters this by stating
that this request from Doom was a ruse
for two reasons the first is that with
all the power he possesses doom could
simply eliminate the Marvel Zombies in
the Ultron robots with almost no effort
the second is because like Johnny Storm
doom felt threatened the reason being
that prior to the collapse of the
multiverse Ben Grimm existed as part of
the Fantastic Four
and worked at forth of various schemes
of doom furthermore while Ben does not
remember any of this because it was
unaffected by the memory modifications
that doom employed Thanos does in
addition it seems that at some point in
the past Johnny Storm became aware of
what was happening and as a result doom
cast him into the sky to exist as the
Sun feeding on Ben Grimm's pride and
recognition that with Thanos says is
true the story comes to an end as Ben
Grimm seemingly abandons his role as the
wall separating the Marvel Zombies in
the Ultron robots from everyone else and
joins in the uprising against dues rule
over battle world
so continuing our discussion on Secret
Wars the events in this story provide us
with some insight into what happened to
the various characters who were
transported across battle world by
Doctor Strange prior to his death at the
hands of doom but also brings the
rumblings of revolution into full swing
before we get into this though something
I want to touch on here are the
territories of bar-sinister
and Ferno and Age of Apocalypse due to
the fact that the armies of these three
territories will be a major part of the
revolution in this story bar-sinister is
pretty straightforward and that it's run
by mr. sinister presumably the version
from the main Marvel Universe and
occupied entirely of clones of himself
Inferno is a territory based on the 1988
story of the same name where it was
revealed that a woman named Madeline
prior was a clone of Jean Grey created
by mr. sinister and introduced after
Jean Grey died in an effort to procreate
with Scott Summers and produce a trial
with incredible power who would actually
go on to become cable during the inferno
event Madeline prior had lost her mind
after learning that she was a clone and
in turn allied herself with demons from
the dimension of limbo attempted an
invasion and takeover of earth but
ultimately failed however in terms of
the battle world territory and the
character that we'll see in this story
this version of Madeline hails from a
universe where she was successful in
taking over the world
finally Age of Apocalypse is another
straightforward story which focus on a
universe where apocalypse was never
destroyed by magneto during the Age of
Apocalypse event and instead continued
to rule the world now in terms of Secret
Wars when we covered issues 4 & 5 I'd
left out a couple of segments since I
didn't play a major role at the time but
because of the events taking place in
part 7 we need to jump back and cover a
couple of these things and in number
four when Doctor Strange has stood
against doom over the fact that he had
created battle world as a testing ground
rather than a utopia during the conflict
strange a teleporter the survivors of
the ultimate universe and the main
Marvel Universe two different locations
across battle world where issues 5 & 6
largely focus on both versions of Reed
Richards from the Ultimate Universe and
may marvel universe respectively as well
as Peter Parker and Miles Morales and
their efforts to locate the source of
dooms power and eliminate it this story
also explained what happened at Jane
Foster Thor Carol Danvers black panther
and name of the Submariner while it's
only given over a single page Jane
Foster had been transported a doomguard
the location where the Thor Corps
resides as a police force a battle world
under doom
my Panther and name of the sub-mariner
had been transported to Egyptian a
section a battle war from a universe
where Moses never led an exodus from
Egypt and Carol Danvers had been sent to
bar-sinister in addition to this with
our last video we a touched on the idea
of an enigmatic being named the prophet
leading a revolution and battleworld
taking a sort of Game of Thrones
attitude to the story take - Tobler said
on its face the bearers of battle world
under doom were all loyal without
question
but in truth were completely split down
the middle now something I want to do
here real quick is talk about maestro or
the future and perfect story saw him
stuck in his own head and destined to
spend the rest of his life believing
that he had defeated doom and the main
secret war story he's in his normal form
and perfectly aware of everything that's
going on
well Hickman may or may not explain how
this happened this particular issue is
one of the reasons why tie-ins can be a
problem for major stories there's no
real unifying element except for the
story itself and so we don't really have
a choice here but to assume that either
the tie-in didn't happen or something
took place to rouse the maestro out of
his illusion but regardless in terms of
the story what Hickman does here is play
on the arrogance of doom and that he
assumes that his barons are loyal to a
fault while some like apocalypse follow
doom due to his belief of survival of
the fittest and only the strongest
should rule others like sinister have
more ambiguous motives and so all of
this comes to a head in issue number 7
when we pick up with a fallout of the
prophets revolt growing beyond control
amassing an army huge in size and
composed of various characters from
throughout battle world some of whom had
powers of some of whom don't the
revolution comes knocking on the door of
doom stat where it's revealed that the
Prophet is none other than Maximus the
mad now for those who are unaware
Maximus is the inhuman brother of Black
Bolt king of the Inhumans but also
possesses a genius-level intellect as a
result of his exposure to the Terrigen
mists like the other survivors of the
Ultimate Universe and the main Marvel
Universe Maximus seems to be leading
this revolution for the purpose of
toppling doom whether this is due to
altruism and that he's trying to do the
right thing or because he has his own
motives is unknown
since Maximus himself is ambiguous when
it comes to his motives for any
particular situation however the schemes
of Maximus are short-lived in the face
of the combined efforts of bar-sinister
Madeline Pryor and her goblins and
apocalypses forces seeing this as an
opportunity to turn against Duman in his
rule sinister turncoats and along
Carol Danvers their forces at HACC
Madeline Pryor and her army of goblins
however in the mists of their attack on
Madeline enter goblins sinister is
caught unawares by an explosion from
behind resulting in his head being
severed from his neck and when the smoke
clears he's greeted by the arrival of
Holocaust decide track for a second
Holocaust was it being originating from
the Age of Apocalypse story with unknown
origins while it was claimed that he was
the son of apocalypse this has largely
left ambiguous and instead he simply
served as one of apocalypses four
horsemen furthermore with apocalypse
arriving on the battlefield the
indication from Hickman seems to be that
because apocalypse was serving as a
baron of the Age of Apocalypse territory
but was unable to move outside of his
own boundaries he quite literally grew
bored of stagnation as a result he
delights in the idea of being on a
battlefield and testing the weak so
though they can prove themselves strong
or be destroyed and so after a bit of
banter between apocalypse and sinister
himself the battlefield is met with the
arrival of the Thor Corps however rather
than being there for the purpose of
quelling the conflict it's revealed that
Jane Foster has incited revolution
within the range of the Thor Corps after
revealing the truth of battle world and
that doom is not a god but an
all-powerful being who put realities
together after the collapse of the
multiverse as a result the Thor Corps is
in complete and total disarray with
civil war breaking out between those who
believe Jane Foster and those who don't
where the battle is short-lived with
Jane Foster ultimate Thor and others
coming out on top the group takes their
lead from dim guard at which point the
entire battlefield descends into
complete and total chaos with the
remnants of the Thor Corps fighting
against the forces of apocalypse and
Madeline prior by a-lying themselves
against doom with sinister and Carol
Danvers Susan storm Valeria Richards and
Black Swan watch alongside doom as a
situation unfolds now what hitman does
here is used a situation to provide to
sin among the ranks of Doom zone house
and not to Susan storm the Thor course
war absolute allegiance to doom and has
obeyed every order without question
however suddenly the Thor Corps has
turned against doom indicating that they
know something that Susan doesn't which
has caused them to turn against doom and
join the revolution now back on the
battlefield what Hickman does is provide
those of us who are apocalypse fans with
a true depiction of his power and that
he single-handedly is able to take on a
full contingent of the Thor Corps if I
can be a little bold here this is
particularly awesome to me because I've
been in the park
fan for years and I felt like this
display was a reflection of just how
powerful of hoc ellipse is in that
between a shape-shifting control of his
atomic structure and so on he's someone
that could easily stand against some of
the strongest foes however in the midst
of the fight the battlefield is met with
the arrival of maestro and his army of
hulks referred to as the world breakers
all of whom possess the same level of
strength as world breaker Hulk from the
world war hulk storyline at this point
we transition to project 42 with the
ultimate and main Marvel versions of
Reed Richards what we learn is that this
entire revolution as it's being led by
Maximus including Sinister's betrayal
and the arrival of the hoax has all been
orchestrated by ultimate read as a
distraction that will allow himself the
main Marvel read and star-lord to enter
the castle of doom alongside black
panther with the Infinity Gauntlet and
in his rule now the conversation between
Reed Richards and black panther is of
stupendous importance here and that the
two are extremely close friends by way
of their intelligence as well as the
experiences that they've shared as part
of the Illuminati and so that you
recognize that their mission is quite
literally a last-ditch effort scenario
and that if they fail they will likely
die and battleworld will continue under
the rule of doom was also funny here is
the banter between Black Panther and
named war as sworn enemies who both
annihilated the others Empire during
time runs out leading up to secret Wars
the conversation between the two is
filled with charge as much as it is
animosity and so I think a legitimate
argument could be made here that even if
the two aren't the best of friends at
the very least they share a common
respect for one another and so with the
two standing before the walls separating
battle worlds from the dead and Ultron
robots Black Panther destroys the wall
and enters using the power of the
Infinity Gauntlet my Panther is able to
curb the zombies desire for flesh and in
the process offer them a chance to use
the siege courageous to eliminate the
zombie plague from their bodies and
start their lives anew while some stand
against the idea and that they view
their lives as simple due to the fact
that they simply exist to eat flesh and
can't truly die because all of them were
heroes or super-powered beings in some
form of fashion prior to contracted a
zombie plague by Panther appeals to this
aspect of their personalities by telling
them that should they choose to use a
siege courageous to start over they can
fight alongside Black Panther for glory
and honor
so as we get into our video our Secret
Wars part 8 what we're gonna do here is
tie the events of previous issues into
our discussion which should allow for a
smooth continuation of the story so far
but also cover any questions you might
have along the way so in the previous
issue we had talked about how following
the death of dr. strange and the
dispersing of the earth-616 and ultimate
universe heroes and villains across
battleworld
that over the course of several weeks
these various individuals had found
their way into several camps including
Jane Foster in the Thor Corps Carol
Danvers and mr. sinister and so on
however these various threats all came
together when Maximus the mad the
inhuman brother of Black Bolt began
amassing an army to lead a revolution
against doom picking up in the midst of
the battle with the Hulk's Madeline
Pryor's demons and Senators clones the
story shifts his focus to Reed Richards
from earth-616 Reed from The Ultimate
Universe and Peter quill with a group
intended to use the battle as a
distraction to sneak into Castle doom
without anyone noticing
the trio set upon by one of the hoaxes
from my shows army were the actions of
this particular Hulk result and the
engines being destroyed what this does
is set up for the future encounter
between 6-1-6 Reed and the rest of his
family from here we jump to my show at
Castle doom and his attempts to draw out
the good doctor however in the midst of
his rant he's met with the arrival of
Ben Grimm now in one of our previous
videos we discussed how Thanos had
discovered that the shield separating
the Ultron robots the zombies and the
annihilation wave from the rest of
battle world was actually Ben Grimm
himself where we learned that Ben's role
as the wall was a ploy by Doom to
essentially force him out of the picture
and allow the indoctrination of Susan
storm Franklin Richards and Valeri
Richards when Thanos had revealed the
truth of his life prior to the collapse
of the multiverse been abandoned his
role as the shield allowing Thanos to
muster his own army and so what this
section brings to us is the final stop
of Ben's journey and that because he's
seeking revenge against doom he's
effectively taking out everyone that he
perceives to be in his way including the
maestro furthermore where Susan storm
recognizes who Ben is while he served as
the wall doom used that time to modify
her memories and lead her to believe as
she had always been married to doom and
the Franklin and valaria were his
children to this end Susan viewed Ben as
a family friend who may had fought
alongside when they first gained their
powers but to her mind
Reed's never existed
now during this time we also see the
return of Terrax the enlightened for
those of you who never saw my videos on
Hickman's Avengers and New Avengers care
actually enlightened was a Herald of
Galactus from another reality where the
Illuminati of iron man Black Bolt Reed
Richards Doctor Strange and named when
the Submariner attempted to save the
earth in the midst of an incursion they
had also imprisoned hair acts in the
main Marvel Universe where he escaped
alongside Thanos during the multiversal
collapse and so his appearance here
marks only a handful of times that he's
actually shown up for this appearance
here is really just the result of his
efforts to ally himself with Galactus
now Galactus within the context of
battle world is a little confusing and
hasn't been fully fleshed out by hickman
on one hand he seems to be under the
control of Franklin Richards but whether
this is truly a version of Galactus
being controlled or simply a construct
of Franklin using his ability to work
reality is unknown the only thing we
really know here is that Terrax is
considered an enemy of doom and as such
Franklin simply kills him as Ben Grimm
watches on and so with Ben stepping in
to fight Franklin the battle between the
two of them is actually pretty even
because this is largely a physical fight
the indication here is that even if this
is Galactus simply under the control of
Franklin the full measure of his powers
in controlling all things has been
severely diminished in addition to this
where Susan pleads with doom to step in
since any this conflict is well within
his abilities he actually chooses not to
the reason why is revealed when Thanos
arrives with the annihilation horde
decide track for a second the
annihilation horde or the annihilation
wave as it was called prior to Secret
Wars is actually something that we
haven't really talked about before led
by a being named Annihilus the
annihilation wave first appeared during
the annihilation storyline and came with
an AI Alyssa's attempt to wipe out all
life in the main Marvel Universe where
his attempts were unsuccessful and the
story ended with his defeat at some
point during the collapse of the
multiverse the annihilation wave was
collected by doom and housed on battle
world although we never actually see
this happen something to also take note
of here is that during the fight between
Ben and Franklin Ben learns that the
Franklin's mind
he and Valyria are the children of susan
and doom stopping the fight and taking a
few moments to focus on this subject the
full extent of Ben's understanding of
the world around him comes into play
where the actions of doom modifying the
memories of Susan Franklin and valaria
goes deeper than he accept
in addition to this because Susan was
such an intricate part of his life and
he has no desire to fight her son VIN
stands down but rather than Franklin
doing the same
he actually destroys Ben now switching
back to Susan and valaria in our
previous videos we discuss how Valeria's
intelligence allowed her to piecemeal
the evidence together leading her to
realize that her memories in relation to
doom were a lie working to uncover the
truth regarding what happened to her
father between the collapse of the
multiverse and the start of secret wars
while Valyria is still piecing things
together from her perspective this all
seems to be a show by doom in an effort
to continue his deceit and control over
battle world and so coming to the
conclusion that Susan should be made
aware of what's going on valaria intends
to bring her mother to the location of
Owen Reese so that he can inform her of
the truth and everything that's actually
going on transitioning back as star-lord
in the mists of his repair of the ship
in order to ensure that he and the reeds
can escape once their mission is
finished he's met with the arrival of
Black Swan
now again her character is one of many
women during the multiverse of collapse
who went by the name Black Swan and
served doom and his efforts to kill off
the multiversal versions of Owen Reese
but following the great collapse she'd
escaped alongside Thanos and eventually
made her way to doom after the survivors
of the earth-616 and ultimate universe
were dispersed across battle world and
so because black swans served doom with
unwavering loyalty prior to the end of
the multiverse during secret Wars in on
battle world she serves with the same
level of loyalty now where Peter talks a
good talk because Black Swan has
super-strength telepathy flight and
several other abilities star-lord is
outclassed in virtually every way and so
back into a corner and with seemingly
nowhere to go Peter makes a last-ditch
move by revealing a single splinter of
wood doing it at the tree of Idris stole
from the remains of asgaard it's
revealed that the splinter was the last
surviving piece of Groot merging itself
with the world tree Groot effectively
reforms and in the process destroys the
whole of Castle doom now switching back
to the battle and the arrival of Thanos
with the annihilation horn the
confrontation between himself and doom
is actually pretty short here
what Hickman does is continue to build
on the arrogance of doom and that to him
the entire scheme of tano's and
collecting the annihilation hoard was a
waste since doom does not consider them
to be of any importance in addition to
this doom is under the impression that
Thanos can be bought and that doom
offers to make
the Baron of the waste beyond the wall
assuming that he stands down and walks
away however that himself also holds
hubris and that he makes the case that
where he once held absolute power and
the form of the Infinity Gauntlet rather
than using it for his own personal
desires he used to sit as judge for all
things in existence now to be honest
Santos is actually telling a bold-faced
lie here while his time with the
Infinity Gauntlet did see him usurp the
role of eternity as a Supreme Being in
the universe the entire basis behind his
acquisition of power came from the
desire to please mistress of death and
so whether there may be truth to what it
is it he's saying here the actual fact
is that when digging a little deeper
Santos's motivation for the Infinity
Gauntlet was completely human and that
he was rooted in the pursuit of love and
so where he makes the argument that he
doesn't need an infinity gone to take
out doom this claim proves to be a false
one when doom seizes Thanos and
completely disintegrates him now if I
can be a little dangerous here I think
Hickman is actually setting the stage
for the return of mistress death the
reason being because as a physical
embodiment of what it means to die she
was the only cosmic entity that couldn't
be killed when the beyonders began the
conquests of wiping out all life well
I'm probably wrong about this at the
very least I think the death of Thanos
will go towards something bigger since
it seems to be too much of a throwaway
for a Hickman story and so as this issue
comes to an end following the death of
Thanos the battlefield is met with the
opening of the siege courageous with
zombies pouring in from the Gateway
because the Marvel zombies are able to
infect anyone with the zombie plague
regardless of what power they possess
the immediate reaction is one of fear
and that everyone could easily be
converted if they were infected but the
mastermind behind these actions is
revealed when black panther makes his
presence known while wielding the
Infinity Gauntlet setting the stage for
the confrontation and the end of doom
and Secret Wars issue number 9
so what I want to do here is continue
our discussion on Secret Wars with the
last and final issue and something I
also want to point out here is that if
you're looking to get into the main
secret war series including the lead up
to everything that got us here I have a
playlist that you can find in the
description of this video
having said that we're issue seven and
eight saw the coming together of various
armies across a battle world some of
which were designed to overthrow doom
and replace him where others just wanted
freedom as a conclusion of issue number
eight like Panther made his appearance
alongside Namor the Submariner
brandishing the Infinity Gauntlet and
leading a full contingent of Marvel
Zombies and so picking up with issue
number nine we continued the
confrontation between de chollet and
Doctor Doom now what's interesting about
this is that initially doom attributes
the surge of armies rising against him
as the work of T'Challa but as we
discussed in one of our previous videos
this was actually orchestrated by the
combined efforts of both versions of
Reed Richards from the earth-616 and
Ultimate Universe respectively with
Maximus the mad operating as a figure
who could rally these armies together
allowing for both versions of Reed to
operate from the shadows in addition to
this doom actually tries to sway them to
his side by appealing to their roles as
Kings what I mean here is that prior to
the events of time lines out which saw
Namor in touch all at waging war against
one another resulting in their kingdoms
destructions name or world over Atlantis
and to child world over Wakanda with
each individual dealing with their own
burdens and that the outside world was
constantly attending to attain wakanda's
vibranium stores while simultaneously
encroaching on the ocean territories of
namur however T'Challa and Namor
ultimately reject the olive branch
offered by doom and using the Infinity
Gauntlet ability to control all things
turned doomed a glass with the intention
of killing him now something to point
out here is that what we're seeing at
the moment is actually something we've
never seen before what I mean here is
that historically the Infinity Gauntlet
has been used by various individuals in
the past but never against someone
wielding the power of the beyonders
because the beyonders were capable of
eliminating the cosmic entities up to
and including the Living Tribunal the
question being asked here is this is
dude truly using the full power of the
beyonders the reason why I asked this
question is that during the events of
infinity war at least assuming that had
been considered it to be official
material the Living Tribunal had rebuked
Adam warlocks claim regarding the
continents incredible power by quite
literally keeping him from being able to
use it temporarily and so using the
transitive property we can argue that if
the beyonders have the power to destroy
a lone tribunal and
tribunal had the power to quell the
Infinity Gauntlet then it stands to
reason that the beyonders are more
powerful than the Infinity Gauntlet
however the issue that we face here is
that there don't actually seem to be any
beyonders left and the last vestiges of
their power rests in the hands of doom
by way of molecule man and where Victor
is able to reconstitute himself after
numerous attack he greets T'Challa as an
enemy with a to doing battle meaning
that unless we're provided a definitive
answer at this part of the story we
don't know which one of the two is
stronger from here Hickman switches our
focus to both versions of Reed meeting
Susan storm and valaria now this is of
stupendous importance in that this is
the first time Reed and Susan have met
since the collapse of the multiverse and
her presumed death where our previous
videos established that Reed had become
aware that Susan was alive and operating
under the control of Victor Hickman's
portrayal of Reed and the inherent issue
of his character during the events of
future foundation are carried over to
his reuniting with Susan what I mean
here is that during Hickman's run a
fantastic for the plot of the story
revolved around Reed's disconnect with
his family and the face of his love for
science technology and solving the
world's problems were the conclusion of
future foundation and the arrival of
Franklin from the future solve this
problem by illustrating the need for
Reed to exist as a family man the lack
of affection towards Susan as displayed
here coupled with the anger he clearly
shows towards new manipulations of
Susan's mind tells us that Reed still
cares for his family but in this
instance stopping doom stripping him of
his power and turning things to the way
they were is of the utmost importance to
this end when the question is asked by
Susan as to who Reed truly is rather
than revealing himself as her husband he
simply states that he's there to fix
things now at this point we follow both
versions of Reed into the secret lair of
dr. doom which is designed to house a
contained molecule man now we're
ultimately was originally brought to us
as a villain over the course of his
publications in the Ultimate Universe
when the collapse of the multiverse
occurred he survived and encountered the
main Marvel Reed Hickman played a bit of
deception and that were ultimately it's
still demonstrated patterns of villainy
it was believed at least by me anyway
that the villainous nature of his
character had taken a backseat to the
necessity of destroying doom however
this proves not to be the case and that
when both versions of Reed encounter
molecule man also meant Reed traps the
main Marvel read in a bubble of time
in addition to this what we're told is
that because of the nature of
battleworld tom was believed to flow
forward only with the inability to flow
backwards meaning the time travel to the
past was impossible the reason for this
was due to the fact the battle wood was
created with the power of the beyonders
and his beings who only existed linearly
meaning they could only move forward in
time the belief was at battleworld
function in the same way now to be
honest here I would argue that this was
the moment when Marvell deviated away
from the idea of rebooting their
continuity and chose to keep it the same
but this is something that we'll discuss
later in story for now the actions of
ultimate Reed's wrapping his counterpart
in a sphere of time causing him to
travel backwards and forwards is rooted
in the idea that ultimate Reed intends
to eliminate his counterpart or at the
very least immobilize them entirely
however during the taunts Owen Reese
steps in Byram aterial izing ultimate
Reed into food but he can actually
consume effectively removing him from
the picture now the reason for why
molecule man chose to intervene isn't
really explained here with the exception
of a warning to the last remaining Reed
the Victor Von Doom is coming but I
would argue but this is really just omen
Reese satisfying his hunger due to the
vast amount of power he possesses and in
doing so elected to kill the villain
rather than the hero but regardless
shifted this way back to doom
temporarily we learn that the power of
the beyonders is indeed greater than the
gauntlet in that doom is essentially
beating and toying with T'Challa however
despite all his vaunted power and
knowledge it's not until today all abhi
Ginn's to taunt doom that Victor
realizes that de chollet went into the
conflict knowing it was impossible for
him to win and that all of the events
have transpired from the first battle at
Castle doom up until the current moment
have all been a ruse designed to allow
both versions of read the opportunity to
locate doom source of power and attempt
to destroy it now travelling to Owen in
an effort to stop Reed from whatever his
mecha Nations happen to be in my opinion
this portion of the story provides us
with one of the best doom monologues in
the history of Marvel Comics what we're
told is that were previously Douma
considered himself to be more capable
than Reed based simply on their
knowledge of science and technology or
willingness to do what needed to be done
at the moment doom considers himself to
be a better man due to his actions at
the cusp of the multiverses collapse
because dooms strange and Owen Reese
stood at the brink of the multiverses
destruction face the beyonders overcame
them and took their
doom used the opportunity to create
battle world and in doing so saved
millions of beings from the fragments of
alternate realities it hadn't yet been
completely destroyed as a result because
reed was only able to save himself and a
handful of others dooms taunts amount to
calling reed a coward in a failure due
to his inability to save his own family
now where doom attempts to kill Reed
using his vast powers the true nature of
Owen Reese comes into play and that
rather than operating simply as a source
of dooms power
Reese is more akin to a gatekeeper
holding the keys and allowing doom to
use the power of the beyonders this
particular bit comes to light when Owen
bestows Reed with the power equal to
doom allowing the two to engage in a
grudge fight of sorts now the battle
between Reed and doom as is written here
is absolutely amazing and that Hickman
is giving us an instance where every
ounce of frustration and anger is being
laid bare from the perspective of doom
despite the various powers he's gained
over the years and the struggles that
he's endured his life has never been an
easy one to sidetrack for a second this
is actually Hickman paying homage to
dooms attempts to save his mother's soul
from Mephisto with his various schemes
over the years designed to acquire the
power to do so as a result dooms anger
towards Reed and stopping his conquest
over the years isn't rooted in the fact
that he was defeated so much as it was
rooted in the fact that Reed had
essentially been stopping doom from
saving his mother on the other hand
Reed's anger towards doom is much
simpler in that when the multiverse
collapsed rather than saving Susan
Franklinville area and been keeping them
whole and waiting for Reed once he
arrived instead doom attempted to take
his place by stripping Reed's family of
their knowledge of him and acting as
Reed himself having said that the battle
between the two comes to a head when du
makes the argument that Reed believes
he's a better person and that have
granted the power of the beyonders he
would have made a better world rather
than creating one of conflict and
turmoil furthermore when Reed forces
Doom to admit that this is true
following this statement I win Reese
makes the case that if both Doom and
Reed agree that Reed would have made a
better world then the opportunity will
be granted for Reed to prove it and so
using his power to effectively wipe the
slate clean as bad a world and all
things with n are completely eliminated
T'Challa seizes the time gem of the
Infinity Gauntlet and a last bid to save
himself
from here things get a little hairy but
they get really interesting at the same
time and that we actually jump back to
when the incursions first began with a
retelling of Avengers vol 3 issue number
one what this tells us is that while
it's not shown Reid seems to have
somehow either stopped the incursions
from happening or else change the
outcome and that T'Challa has
successfully traveled to the past with a
time Jim being destroyed once he arrived
in addition to this where the beginning
of the incursions open with Black
Panther witnessing and in cursive earth
preparing to crash into the main Marvel
Universe followed by the appearance of
Black Swan all actions of T'Challa and
his tribesmen appear to be the same here
with the exception of the fact that
rather than witnessing an incursion take
place they witness the launching of a
vessel into space for the purpose of
exploration from here we jump to Miles
Morales in Peter Parker where miles has
a flashback to Owen thanking him for
bringing a hamburger what this tells us
is that Miles Morales still remembers
everything that had taken place during
the events of secret wars on battle
world where Owen had responded to models
by saving that he owes m1 this favour
seems to have come to fruition with
Miles being thrown into the same
universe as Peter allowing for miles to
fight alongside his hero against various
villains and so as the story begins to
come to a close Hickman brings a
conclusion of secret Wars into full view
by telling us how things have changed
and setting the stage for the direction
of the future of Marvel Comics what
we're told is that the incursions the
destruction of the multiverse and the
death of the cosmic entities all took
place meaning that as of this moment
with the exception of Galactus in The
Ultimates there don't seem to be any
cosmic entities in the all-new
all-different marvel universe in
addition to this where the beyonders
were essentially defeated by Doctor
Strange dr. doom and Owen Reese rather
than doom using the power of the
beyonders to create battle world the
process of recreating all things fell to
Reed Franklin and Owen Reese with the
explanation coming to Susan by way of
Valyria Owen Reese exists as a battery
of sorts and that he's the source of the
beyonders power and the ability to
create things at the same time
Franklin is both a universal and
multiversal constant meaning that he's
able to tap into the power of Owen Reese
and use it to create universes finally
with Reed's vast intellect and
experience the abilities of Owen and
Franklin are combined allowing for Reed
to instruct Franklin on how to engineer
universes and send them off into the
multiverse to function and grow on their
own and so what Hickman is essentially
telling us is that what Reed is viewed
as the savior of the multiverse due to
battleworld having never happened and
all-new all-different marvel the reason
why Reed Susanville area and Franklin
aren't present in any existing stories
is due to the fact that they're quite
literally engineering universes to
recreate the multiverse with each
reality containing its own molecule man
now in truth this is really just an
opportunity for Marvel to shuffle a
Fantastic Four out of the landscape and
keep them out of stories similar what
was done with Nick Fury during original
sin this is evident in the fact that
when Franklin asks if they're
superheroes anymore Reed responds by
saying that their work won't stop it's
simply creating universes and that all
of these alternate realities have to be
catalogued monitored and maintained
until they grow to the point of becoming
self-sustaining after which time the
Fantastic Four will return furthermore
in the closing pages of the story is
revealed that throughout his entire
ordeal from the start of the incursions
his journey to find his family his
battle with doom and Owen Reese
resetting the events after the
multiversal collapse allowing for the
recreation of all things Reed himself
had to learn multiple lessons and that
the failure of doom was his desire to
hold on to everything he had for fear of
losing it and that this fear was
ultimately his downfall
and that he was essentially a man
holding his life in his hands with no
foundation but as soon as the things
that doom loved were taken away from him
he was essentially a broken man using
this as a platform Reed intends to use
the time engineering universes to
connect with his family
connect with what it means to live and
rather than holding on so tight to the
things he loves simply allow the
universe to grow and function as it
should
with that being said we're gonna bring
this video to an end and let me know
down in the comment section what you
guys think about Secret Wars so far and
be sure to check that link in the
description if you want to watch the
whole thing even waiting all this time
for me to finally get the last video out
and now you want to be enjoy chit which
I'm not against it'd be awesome but let
me know and I will catch you guys later
peace
[Music]